welcome to one of the most formative and
terrifying time periods ever the
cenozoic era you'll find giant creatures
like woolly mammoths and megalodons
roaming the Seas along with some other
creatures you might be a little bit more
familiar with but more on that later
let's strap in and travel back in time
to the Cena zoic era how would you
survive during this per period why was
Earth so
dangerous and how is this era similar to
modern
day this is what if and here's what
would happen if you traveled to the
cenozoic
era okay you're now 66 million years in
the past you just missed the age of
dinosaurs by a couple of million years
they were wiped out by a giant asteroid
and are now extinct but that doesn't
mean that other life hasn't found a way
the death of the dinos made way for new
creatures to emerge
mammals yeah the early cenozoic period
saw the rise of primitive mammals that
would begin to diversify into different
evolutionary niches let's explore and
check them out one of the most famous
mammals during this time was the
meapa these were giant creatures that
roam the earth a lot of these probably
look familiar go to the colder regions
of the earth and you'll find packs of
woolly mammoths roaming about these guys
were nearly 3 and 1/2 M tall and weighed
up to 8
tons okay go over to what's now known as
Australia and you'll see the
diprotodon this is the biggest marsupial
that ever lived and looks like a giant
wombat and it wasn't just the mammals
that were Giant watch out in the water
because you'll be met with one of the
most terrifying creatures ever the
Megalodon this giant shark dominated the
oceans with teeth as big as 18 cm and a
body as long as 20
m i could go on but we have so much more
to
explore as the rise of mammals happened
many of them went extinct and
unfortunately stuff like that is still
going on today luckily our friends over
at Planet wild are working on solutions
to stop that from happening and you can
help too right from your couch stick
around till the end of the video for
more info on how you can help let's
check out a couple of other creatures
and then I'm going to show you something
really cool the scoic era also had the
glyptodon which was like a Giant
armadillo the megatherium a giant sloth
and one of the largest of the mammals
and the elas smum also known as the
Siberian unicorn it was basically a
woolly version of a rhinoceros and there
were a bunch more creatures but why were
they all so
big well researchers have several
different theories as to why these
creatures became so massive one of the
leading ones is that with the Dinosaurs
gone these mammals could thrive in open
habitats helping them grow larger and
larger as Generations progress
but there's another incredibly important
mammal I haven't mentioned yet and
although it's not a giant it is one of
the most
important and that's you well sort of
humans early ancestors were
primates with the death of the Dinosaurs
the rise of primates became possible
allowing them to evolve early primates
were small and weak creatures when the
scoic era started but they had two key
features to help them become dominant
grasping fingers and forward-facing
eyes over millions of years they
survived and later thrived on Earth this
led to primates diversifying and the
emergence of different species which
then gave us two main groups the
primates who would later evolve into
monkeys and apes and the hominids who
would later evolve into humans but this
was happen for millions of years as the
scoic era progressed hominids learned
how to use tools control fire and
develop the beginnings of early
language as more and more hominids
appeared they spread globally and could
be found in Asia Europe Africa and North
America some of these species died out
specifically the neander they evolved
outside of Africa and adapted to live
life in Eurasia but as modern humans
progressed they were more
technologically advanced eventually
leading to the extinction of the
neandertal as more and more species of
hominids evolved more and more died out
the only ones to survive were the homo
sapiens who stayed in Africa their
brains continued to grow leading to more
advanced language technology culture and
eventually
you speaking of you how would you you
survive in this era well to do that it'd
be helpful to know what the cenozoic era
was made up of after all it spanned tens
of millions of years and a lot of stuff
happened the scoic era is divided into
three time periods the paleogene neogene
and the quinary period let's quickly
break them down paleogene period this
marked the start of the scoic era the
mammals we've been talking about along
with flowering plants have begun to
emerge oh and watch out for some creepy
looking
insects earth's tectonic plates
continued to shape continents as they
have been for many millions of years
South America and Africa would continue
to move apart and the Himalayas would
begin to form you'd notice a generally
warm and comfortable climate but that
would start to change as you move into
the next era Neo Gene period okay the
hominids we've been talking about have
now appeared and more modern plants and
animals have begun to evolve one of the
main things you'll notice is how much
colder it's getting ice ages are
becoming more common during this period
quinary period this period had multiple
ice ages and interglacial moments the
Earth cooled down and heated up several
times humans along with the large
mammals we mentioned mentioned earlier
had more impact than ever before this
period is also known as the anthropos
scene which recognizes the significant
impact humans had on the Earth's
ecosystem and
geology so how would you survive during
these
times well it would be much easier than
if you were to live in a time period
even further away hundreds of millions
of years ago Earth had more oxygen which
would make breathing more difficult but
luckily you don't need to worry about
that you just have to be wary of the
giant animals trying to kill you the
unpredictable weather and the weird
kinds of foods that could make you
sick sounds easy right hopefully you'll
be able to Cozy up with some early
hominids and join their tribe they'll
have access to shelter fire and tools
and if you can't manage to do that well
find a cave make a fire and hope for the
best but wait you're technically
surviving in the scoic era right now
yeah that's right this era hasn't ended
yet we're currently living in the
quinary period eras on Earth are
typically marked by Major geological
shifts or mass extinctions neither of
which we've had to deal with
luckily but what if we did what if
Humanity suddenly went extinct would
that Mark the start of a new era well
that sounds like a story for
another what if hey don't click off just
yet as a thank you for making it to the
end of the video I have a gift for you
our friends at Planet wild are going on
monthly missions to help preserve nature
and bring back endangered species all
the while documenting their progress on
YouTube in their latest Mission they're
using honeybees to save elephants and
protect Farmers crops in Tanzania it's
all funded by a community that wants to
give Back To Nature by funding ecosystem
restoration missions where it really
matters by being a member of the planet
Wild app you also get to vote on what
you'd like your funds to be used for
I've been subscribed to it for a while
now and I like how I can track their
progress and find videos documenting
their missions I love the app so much
that I want you to try it out for free
that's why the first 200 people that
sign up will get the first month on me
just click on the link in the
description or scan the QR code and use
the Creator code what
[Music]
if